but i think sometimes people like with a
happiness project people are like i
really want to do this but my partner
isn't excited i'm like my partner's
never been excited my husband
has never done one thing he's not
interested at all that's not the guy i
married i don't have to wait for him to
get on board
why would i frustrate myself in him it's
not his thing
um fine so i just do what but
does he benefit from it 100 would he
tell you that absolutely
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense i mean what could be better than
having someone on the show
that wrote a book called the happiness
project
i mean don't we all want to be happier
now i'm going to bum you out by saying
that there's no magic there's no magic
formula to it
other than the fact that it's all right
there and it's about figuring it out
yourself
knowing that it's within your power
means you know get your butt in gear and
figure out what really makes you happy
her name is gretchen rubin she's an
author she also authored another book
called the four tendencies
i took the test and i'm not gonna lie i
was totally surprised uh
that i was not a rebel
and i was not uh a questioner
uh the four tendencies are upholder
obliger questioner and rebel
and look the two that i thought i was i
wasn't so turns out i'm an upholder
um but anyway uh you can take the test
yourself on her website
um millions of people already have but i
just love learning about people
and and of course myself too but how we
relate to each other
and sometimes when you learn about
people's tendencies like let's say
you're
you're with a questioner because they've
taken this test now when they question
you they're not really questioning you
they're just being themselves and asking
questions so
these coping mechanisms are just at
least understandings can create so much
more empathy in our lives which then
will
of course um not make us feel offended
and will then
bring us more happiness her new book out
is called
outer order inner calm you can pick that
up
anywhere you find books along with all
of our other fantastic books the four
tenancies happiness project and many
more so
enjoy today's episode it's growth right
which i
found out is your word of the year is
this true or am i looking at my or am i
reading
of three-year-old data no it is that was
my year for 2019.
my word for 2019. mine too is it really
yep
do you pick a word every year yeah i
have for about five or six years
what have your other words been um
um uh um what was my one last year uh
truth
that was a big year 17 was a big year
with truth
um open was last year and this year
is growth and have you thought about
2020 yeah
no not yet i'm thinking a really boring
word
but it's very tied to growth which is
infrastructure
okay i need more infrastructure i want
to hear more about growth though
yeah i mean we're kind of coming to a
close like how has your word gone
first off why do you have a word of the
year um i pick i've picked a word of the
year for a very long time just because
um i feel like it it's clarifying to
have like one thing that you're thinking
about
and just sort of keep keep it uppermost
and by having something very distilled
forces me to really think about what is
my top what what it was what is it that
i really want to focus on and i can keep
it
how often do you actually think about
your word of the year
growth i think about all the time
you know all my words i think i think
about all the time i have the word
delegate one year
then i think about delegate all the time
i'm very bad at delegating
so that's more of an aspirational word
um but i have done more delegating um
but no i think about it a lot and i have
it like on my bulletin board
i've heard of people doing funny things
like you know putting you know getting
jewelry with their word
or using as their on their screensaver
or something like that so that they're
constantly reminded of it
how often do you think about your words
since we have the same word yeah uh
i think about it i think i
to answer that question first i think
about it
[Music]
maybe once a week right like consciously
thinking
oh yeah that's my word of the year maybe
maybe once every other week even yeah
but now i do believe
it has become more of an integrated
mindset
which comes just from the repetition yes
yeah i think the repetition is really
helpful well that's just something very
yeah very concise that just sort of says
it all
yeah yeah yeah what um what have uh what
what has helped you what have you what
choices have you made based on your word
um i have like i switched
from i switched like my my uh my email
provider because i thought it would help
me grow which it has
um i have just been very focused on
doing things to try to you know
grow in all ways next year i'm trying
something where
each quarter i'm going to focus on one
area because i felt like i was a little
bit scatter shot like i was trying to
grow in all areas at all times and i
think maybe it would be better to be
like
really gonna double down on this and
just like like throw everything at this
one aim and not worry about everything
all the time
and then move on and that way i can
identify and then really like
gear up and focus on it and push things
forward because sometimes it's like i
feel like
i have so many balls in the air i really
which is not my nature my nature is to
do one thing at a time
and so i feel like sometimes it
dissipates my energy and my focus
and keeps me from growing i want to grow
in all directions but maybe i need to do
it
um in sequence rather than all at one
time so picking an area to grow
right so three months and then and then
it's also like by that time you probably
have like sort of done what you can do
at this point and then i'll move on to
something different
right it's almost like the happiness
project
done quarterly yes that's a good point
i'm very systematic it's very true and
then it's like
i'll check the box off and i'll feel so
good well i've also
i also loved uh that i read that
if you put it on a list that happens and
my girlfriends and i have this complete
theory
that we came up with it when we were
drinking one night
because well actually it was from
drinking we're putting it on our
calendars we're going
here this day next week and then the day
came
and we actually did it and we're like
wow that oh wow
it happened i guess all you have to do
is put it in your phone because it's one
thing to theorize about all the fun
things you want to do when you're
having some wine it's another thing to
actually execute but there was some
magic putting it down in our phones or
putting it on paper
absolutely to make it happen yeah yeah
that whole we should get lunch sometime
it's like yeah we're not going to get
lunch
it's gotta be on the calendar but if it
was in your calendar then you'd show up
it would most definitely happen um so i
took your tenancy test today
excellent yes and i totally thought
that i would be either a rebel uh-huh or
i thought i would be a questioner uh-huh
turns out i am an upholder
interesting well that's what i am too
really but you know the funny thing is
it's a pretty small group
we're kind of an extreme fringe
personality right yeah what is the
breakdown
rebel is the smallest and upholder is
just a little bit bigger
the biggest one for both men and women
is obliger that's like you there aren't
a blighter you have many obligers in
your life they're a big tendency
and then questioners is not as is is not
as big but it's there's a lot of people
who are questioners
um so yeah you and i are kind of part of
the freaky friends
interesting but that you sort of feel
like
you're not like most people or like you
like a lot of times when the folders get
together they're like why can't other
people get their stuff done
like you can just get it together yeah
this is the one let's go that's the
thing that upholders are always saying
to each other
yeah questioners are all being like why
is it everybody's just such lemmings
like they just go along with anything
like what is their problem like they're
confu
every tendency is confused by the other
tendencies they're like what is up
how did you come up with this you know
it was very ordinary
comment that a friend of mine made she
said to me um
because i am my sister calls me a
happiness bully and i will kind of like
get in people's face
i'm a workout bully so yeah it's good to
know that we have maybe it has to do
with their tendencies
probably yeah are always trying to like
chivvy people along
um and so i was asking her about her
habits and her happiness and she said
well the thing about me
is i know i would be happier if i
exercised and the weird thing is when i
was in high school i was on the track
team and i never missed track practice
so why can't i go running now and i
thought well why
i mean what's the difference at one time
it was effortless and now she can't do
it how do you explain that
so i you could generate 10 different
hypotheses about why that might have
been and i was like
but i want to figure out like what is
really making the difference and so i
started really thinking about that and
then i started noticing other patterns
like there's a certain number of people
that if you say
how do you feel about new year's
resolutions because somebody i wrote a
book better than before all about habit
change and so i was always asking people
about new year's resolutions because
it's a good way to get an
insight into how they view habits and a
big group of people would say to me
like in exactly the same words they
would say
i would make a resolution whenever it
made sense i would not wait for january
1st because january 1st is an arbitrary
date
and they use that word arbitrary and i
thought the arbitrariness of it never
really
bothered me i don't really care that
it's arbitrary but clearly for some
people that's very
distressing and so i started trying to
figure out how do you explain these
patterns and why people
did things or didn't do certain things
and after just a huge amount of thought
i got to the four tenancies and
understanding that it's really this idea
of expectation
of meeting outer expectations and
meeting inner expectations that's
makes the difference was there studies
well you know since i just did it
observationally this is just like i'm
more like
you know like montaigne or la france or
samuel johnson like i just observed this
in the world
i think it's very obvious once you know
it like i can do the game of thrones
characters i can do parks and recreation
i can tell you like 15 different movies
that
you know and people i can predict what
people are pretty consistently and i can
also predict how they will behave in the
future and like
what they experienced in the past so i
think it's very stable that's being a
psychic by the way
no no it's because these things are such
patterns we're like yeah i'm so
idiosyncratic no one's ever seen anyone
like me and i'm like okay literally like
that there's a
paragraph in my book talking about how
often this comes up
um but somebody is doing studies and i'm
and other people keep saying that they
are going to study it i just don't have
the wherewithal to like run an actual
scientific study to
test the you know the personality
portion of it well it resonates
i mean at the end of the day it's a tool
it's a useful tool
the true test is like does it resonate
with you yeah it makes sense and it can
help you
doesn't figure out how to make change
because i'm sure you've seen this too is
like
sometimes people they're desperate to
make a change but they don't
they're just throwing spaghetti against
the wall they don't understand like
should i take a class
right should i not take that class
should i do it in the morning should i
do it at night
you know they're just like trying random
stuff and i'm like okay this will tell
you
what is likely to work with you and if
you're having a challenge what's likely
to
fix address it yeah where where do you
see this showing up as being really
helpful
like how does this help in a
relationship how does this help it does
it work
and like what is the what is the
why should everyone know their tendency
and no other people's support tendencies
really quick actually that'd be great
yeah absolutely i mean i'm taking it for
granted right now because i've taken the
test and i've read about you know what
it is but okay
so there's upholders questioners
obligers and rebels so we're both the
holders that's pretty unusual
there's not that many upholders so this
is fun um so
what it is it's how you meet outer
expectations and inner expectations
so outer expectations are things like a
work deadline or a request from a friend
and then inner expectations are like my
own desire to keep a new year's
resolution
my own desire to get back into
practicing guitar
so um depending on how you meet outer
and entered that's what determines the
tendency
so upholders readily meet outer and
enter they they meet the work deadline
they keep the new year's resolution
without much fuss they want to know what
others expect from them but what they
expect for themselves are just as
important
so their motto is discipline is my
freedom
then questioners questioners question
all expectations they'll do something if
they think it makes sense
so they hate anything arbitrary or
inefficient or
unjustified anything that meets their
inner standard they will do no problem
but if it fails their
enter standard they'll push back so
their motto is
i'll comply if you convince me why
then there are obligers like my friend
on the track team obligers readily meet
outer expectations but they struggle to
meet inner
so um when there's a team and a coach
waiting for somebody
she shows up no problem when she's going
on her own it's a struggle
and the thing about obligers is if they
want to meet an inner expectation
they have to create some form of outer
accountability got it if i want to
exercise i got to work out with the
trainer if i want to read more i got to
join a book group that's what works
okay so their motto is you can count on
me
and i'm counting on you to count on me
and then finally rebels
resist all expectations outer and inner
like totally yeah they want to do what
they want
to do in their own way in their own time
they can do anything they want to do
anything they choose to do they often
love a challenge
but if you ask or tell them to do
something they're very likely to resist
and typically they don't tell themselves
what to do like they won't decide that
they're going to take a 10 a.m spin
class every saturday
because they're like i don't know what
i'm gonna want to do on saturday oh
that's why i'm not a rebel then
yeah okay right because they're like i
want to just wake up and see how i feel
and the fact that somebody's expecting
me to show up is just gonna annoy me so
their motto is you can't make me and
neither can i
um so those are the four um
yes it's so cool how you identify with
them it reminds me very much of like
five love languages or something like
that where you really strongly identify
with one
um well and usually people can tell what
they are just from a very brief
description but i do have this quiz the
quiz you took at quiz.gretchenreuben.com
like two and a half million people have
taken the quiz now um
yes but um but like i say a lot of times
if you hear the description you're like
one really fits much better than the
others yeah and and take the test
because i was surprised i was an
upholder
i totally thought i was a question or a
rebel so it was very interesting
that i mean of course i read all the
questions answers like
very honest about my answers i'm like
hey i guess i'm gonna uphold her and i
didn't realize well i think sometimes
people like
certain words or certain you know i do
it's interesting
with rubble because some people say to
me like oh you can't call it rubble
because everybody's going to want to say
they're rebel and then other people are
like why would you use the word rebel no
one's going to want to identify as a
rebel and i'm like
interesting that's a little rorschach
test right there right
how how does it i mean how does it
affect your life how does it oh great to
your question of how does it help
well one of the things is you can
understand like
why people are behaving in a different
way or how
or or why you just can't figure out what
their deal is like
as an upholder and maybe you've
experienced this my view is like
i want to do my work in my own way you
can do your work in your own way as long
as we get where we're going it doesn't
matter i don't want to be your
babysitter
i don't want to look over your shoulder
i don't want to tell you how to do your
own business
like let's just let's just let's just
get on with it
move on okay but so i was working with
somebody
who i found out it was an obliger and i
found out that she was very resentful of
the fact that i sent email i sent emails
in the middle of the night
five in the morning christmas day
because i just when i think of it i
wanted to send it that's how i work and
i'm like
you can answer it whenever you like i'm
not telling you have to answer it it's
just like do your work in your way
and i'll do my work in my way um but she
felt like i wasn't respecting the work
day
and then it was creeping into her
leisure and um
resentment was building and the fact is
now i know is an obliger
when she sees this this creates an outer
expectation that she would respond it's
very hard for her to resist that she
feels very uncomfortable with that
pressure
as an upholder i would just ignore that
um
if i felt like it um but for her it was
really
it was not it was uncomfortable so it's
like okay do we have to have a big
argument
do we have to like does she have to do
it my way do i have to do it her way do
we have to go to hr
and have some kind of policy no it's
just now i use delay delivery on outlook
and she gets
10 emails from me every monday morning
at 7 30 a.m
because it's like once i underst i'm
like you feel the way you do
and i feel the way i do and neither one
of us is right neither one of us is
wrong it's just that we
experience the world in a different way
yeah or like questioners a lot of times
people are like oh my gosh
why do you ask so many questions like
too much like who cares
everybody's agreed to this format let's
move on and the questioner's like
why are we doing this way why does this
make sense why are we listening to
corporate like why am i listening to you
if you understand they're not
questioning your judgment they're not
undermining authority they're not being
obstructionist they just need to
understand why
once they they just need to have their
questions answered
there's no they're like this with
everybody it's not about this
relationship
and so it takes a lot of the sting out
of it a lot of times people feel much
more like okay well maybe it's a little
bit annoying but i don't feel attacked
yeah i i feel like just understanding
people's tendencies
it's almost like knowing someone's
family right yeah this is an example
if you know somebody's mom and dad you
can go oh yeah
got it that's why you do that and it's
an explanation
yes i'm an excuse and then you have so
much more forbearance because you're
like okay i get it more empathy
yeah more understanding more patience
yes which leads to a happier existence
well and then you also understand what
other people are bringing to the table
so for like upholders a lot of times
with questioners we're like
we don't need to answer all these
questions let's let's get going but now
like i'm married to a question and i
realized it's so valuable because a lot
of times they'll be like why would you
do that and i'm like
why would i do that like i don't have to
do that yeah so he saves me from work or
like he helps me decide like
is something worth my time yeah i can do
it but do i even need to bother doing it
or like obligers you know obligers are
great to have around they're the people
that go the extra mile
yeah and um to recognize how valuable
they are to teams as leaders
yeah and then rebels are the ones that
could just completely see outside the
box
they can blow it up yeah now that can be
hard to manage sometimes but it can also
be enormously valuable
yeah i think i had an exact scenario
with i think i'm dating a questioner
because there was a question about my
schedule and something that i was doing
and i was like why are you questioning
me
yes like why are you yeah i'm like why
are you sure mining
totally felt undermining like i was not
like i didn't know my job well enough
i didn't know what i was doing like i
didn't do my due diligence yes
and it can make you very defensive very
i got defensive i'm like i know i'm
getting a little defensive but i feel
like i'm being questioned for my
like the ability to be detail-oriented
at all or even just
like delegate so i felt like i was like
i delegated these people yeah planned
this week for me yes and now your
question
makes me question myself that i do a bad
job and
all i'm doing is upholding the schedule
yeah and upholding i'm just i said i
want to come to media yeah
and then media got scheduled so i'm up
holding both ends yeah yeah
and so i totally was offended yes and
but of course it was you know it gets
muddled up and this questioning that
feels
so hurtful and can be very draining too
yeah yeah because you sort of feel like
you're on the stand in a way
have forced to kind of like explain all
the decisions that you've made
so part of it is just to be like i saw
it what i say to my husband sometimes is
i say questions without answers
meaning like you know what i'm just i'm
not going to answer questions anymore
you can do that and the funny thing
about questioners is often they don't
like to answer questions i don't know
this is
not all questioners are like this but
you can yeah that's probably true
he won't answer questions if i don't
actually have to know the answer he will
not answer a question it is
and this is a very widespread pattern
among questioners
and it's super annoying and ironic it is
and yet
it's the thing and again i'm like i i
used to really take it personally and be
like
i would think that he was sort of
jerking my chain just to kind of annoy
me on purpose because he thought it was
funny or something and now i just know
he's like this with everybody yeah it's
not aimed at me it might be annoying
but i don't have to take it personally
and also i can just kind of laugh at it
now we call it
n2k that's need to know basis only
because he's i'm like what time are we
going to brunch and he won't tell me and
i'm like
is this n2k that's so him like he's
right like i'm like what are we doing
he's like i don't know
see this is not like i know you know i
know you have a plan
yeah why won't you tell like yeah this
trip had movement plan i know you just
told me like a day
it is the weirdest thing i have talked
to questions
part of it is they don't like to be
questioned because they feel like
i am so thorough no one should question
my judgment and part of it is like they
because they have thought everything
through they just find it tiresome to
have to do it
i think my husband though once he's made
up his mind how he wants it to go
that's what he wants and he doesn't want
to open it up to challenge
which he knows that if i knew it then i
could maybe
have you know want to so i think a
little bit of it is kind of like
i've come up with the final and best
answer to this yeah and so i'm not
taking
uh comments from the audience anymore
but it is now i have a lot more sense of
humor and it also makes people good to
know it's a common thing
like it's not just like yeah you're like
what's this weird guy
i mean this is the true beta test this
is your test by this is the testing like
right you know i said
have you done any kind of scientific
research was there a study this is the
study well it's an
data but it's very but the thing is
these patterns are very consistent it's
funny
it's like um you see things like rebels
um often when they apply to school
they'll only apply to one school
it's like that's kind of odd but there
it is
it comes up over and over again or i was
just saying
rebels are off rebel children are often
unusually close to their grandparents
because i think it's like unconditional
love it's the love of a fan of
it's family love but without the
expectations that parents have
and so that's something that you can
really if you if you have a rebel child
you could be like huh well maybe i want
to
maybe i want to facilitate more
relationships with grandparents maybe
that'd be a good way for them to connect
with their family if they're pulling
back from me
is this all in the book like all these
examples yeah yeah yeah
because there's all these very very kind
of
unexpected patterns but then once you
see them they're they're very
clear yeah well that's fanta i just i
just love understanding human nature
better
and just being able to understand
because it it's already challenging so
the more we can do to understand each
other
um because it's hard enough to
understand yourself right now just know
yourself
let alone someone else so the more
resources we have to understanding
tendencies and characteristics and
personalities and
you know what people are all about and
what makes them
up that is just kind of there and and i
and i
it's you believe that this is totally a
genetic thing that you're born with
i really do believe in the genetic roots
of personality um i
just that's my own belief and so i think
this is wired
now obviously with time and experience
and culture it would affect it like if
you're a questioner and you're born in
north korea
you're going to shut that down but you
know if you're in silicon valley it
could be your greatest asset right
and so it depends on i think over time
it's like questions going back to
questionnaires
like questionnaire children are often
can be seen as very disrespectful
and sassy yeah um but then often
questioners will learn how to be more
constructive and how to
with experience they learn how to ask
questions in a way that doesn't
that doesn't get under other people's
skin because they've learned how to work
with their tendency
but it's not that they're not still
questioners or like obligers sometimes
obligers are like
oh i wasn't a blighter but now i'm in a
polder and i'm like no you know what i
think has happened i think that you've
intuited
that you need outer accountability to
meet inner expectations and i bet if i
looked at everything and
what it always does it's like oh yeah i
eat healthy now that i'm on weight
watchers and i work out with a trainer
and now i read because i have a book
group and i walk all the time because i
have a dog
and oh my friends and i meet every
wednesday i mean
i'm like you figured it out i figured it
out everyone figures it out but you feel
like an upholder because you're meeting
all the answers yourself
and that's the thing you feel like an
upholder so fine
but the thing is some people don't
figure it out and that's why it's nice
to just tell them what the pattern is
because then they don't have to just
like hit or miss
figure it out in 15 years right it's
just figured out now you figure it out
right now and sometimes
but i want to change i want to learn to
put myself first and make time for
self-care i'm like oh you won't do that
or if you could it would take so much
inner work do the quick easy fix
you say no that won't have time for
self-care but that leads me to the self
which is
you know like like i said it's hard
enough to know someone else let alone
like it's hard enough to know yourself
let alone someone else
so like the happiness project feels like
a total self-care project
oh but see if holders don't have trouble
with self-care because it's an inner
expectation
so it's like you i'm sure if you're an
upholder you're like yeah i'm sorry i
got to work out or like oh we've got
company but i got to go for a run or you
know what i just i feel like i just need
to take an hour and read on the sofa
that is not hard it's obliged whenever
people are talking about having trouble
with self-care that it's a big tip-off
that someone is an obliger because
upholders questioners and rebels
all get that in their own way but for
obligers it's hard because the outer
expectation will always push it aside
and so they need to do things like
arrange figure out ways to get outer
accountability even for something like
getting a massage or you know doing
something that's fun
because they won't need it in our
expectation unless there's utter
accountability for it
so they have to which sounds funny like
somebody i know was an accountability
group
um you know just to like
go to the movies in the afternoon and
i'm like if you're an obliger that could
very well be necessary i think she's
really smart to get herself
accountability
that's what she wants to do for fun why
should she be doing laundry 24 hours a
day on the weekends
you know go to a movie some if you got
to have a friend a friend tell you
it's you got to go to the movie it's
like that's fine whatever it takes
whatever it takes so what did it uh how
did you get the idea
for the happiness project i love this
concept oh yeah
well i ha well i am very systematic as
you pointed out but i was
on a very crowded city bus here in
manhattan
um stuck in the pouring rain so going
very slowly
and i looked out the window and had one
of those opportunities for reflection
and i thought
what do i want from life anyway and i
thought i want to be happy
but i realized i didn't spend any time
thinking about whether i was happy
how old were you uh this was like 12
years ago
um and how i could be happier so i
decided
i should have a happiness project and
that was the phrase that came to me and
so i ran to the library got a giant set
of books like ancient philosophy and
contemporary science and
pop culture and everything about how to
be happy and i was like
can you make yourself happier what would
you do to make yourself happier like
what's
so i started reading and i got so
excited i was like okay i'm really going
to do this
and then it just sort of got bigger and
bigger and bigger until finally i was
like wow maybe this could be my next
book project because it just
it felt like it was going to take a lot
of time to sort of or
like do everything that i wanted to do
and
basically the subject of happiness and
human nature
has been so fascinating that ever since
then i've just been sort of
going so i wrote a book about habits
because obviously habits have a really
important role to play
the four tendencies like i just stumbled
upon
i wrote a little book called outer order
intercom because for most people
not everybody that's your newest book
yeah for most people out of order
contributes to intercom so it's like
kind of funny like why does so many
people feel that it's sort of like in
the context of a happy life a
crowded coat closet doesn't seem like a
big deal and yet you
clean out your coat closet and you feel
like oh my you know
yeah my life has changed if brendan
wayne said i finally cleaned out my
fridge and now i know i can switch
careers i was like
i know exactly how that feels so it just
seemed funny to me so i decided to write
a little book about that
so guys so but the happiness project was
me just sort of
trying to figure out so each one what
are the each month you had a different
goal yeah similar to what you're saying
you should do with your word of the year
but you're talking about doing that a
little bit more like quarterly yeah
let's call it yeah oh seasonally i like
that seasonally that sounds more
pleasant
um yeah so like um january was the month
of energy because i thought well if i
have more energy everything
to follow will be easier because a lot
of times you know perfectly well you
should do something and it would make
you happy
but you're just you're like too tired to
do anything except like
the thing that i always do when i what
did you do when i'm tired is i um
reread magazines i've already read um
that's what you did if you were talking
about
really tired like i think now people
like scroll through instagram
yeah you know it's like you're kind of
in that hypnotic
like you really should go to bed
but you're like you're too tired to go
to bed yeah so one was i focused on
sleep which i'm a huge sleep zealot
one is exercise um one was like
what was creating outer order because
that was because i really do think that
certainly for me and for most people
creating outer order does
contribute to kind of a sense of energy
and calm so those were some of the
things i did that month
yeah so each month i tried to identify
like three to five
very concrete manageable resolutions
that i could
do that would whether it was towards
family or friendship or
money or time um
that i thought might move the needle and
it was always things i think it's
important to really have things that are
very concrete
because sometimes people like what's an
example of something concrete
something's not concrete okay so
sometimes people will have something
like i want to eat healthfully
that's too vague is it like i want to
eat breakfast i want to bring lunch from
home i want to stop eating out of
vending machines i want to quit sugar
like like what is something where at the
end of the day you're like did i do this
or did i not do this
did i eat sugar today that i know did i
eat healthfully it's like
or things like i want to enjoy the
moment what does that mean
how do you know if you've enjoyed the
moment it's like it's a little more
specific
right you could say something like i
want to you know
like some people have like a lucky time
like 11 11 or something like that every
day at 11 11
i'm going to stop and and you know just
take in the world around me or whatever
it is there's a million things you can
do but i think it's important that
you can tell if you've done them or not
they have to be concrete
what was the hardest one
oh the thing that i think well the thing
that didn't work which is like the
classic advice which i'm like the only
happiness commentator
like to naysay is the gratitude journal
i was deeply annoyed by my gratitude
journal i did not
i just did not find that to be a helpful
practice no and okay also meditation
i've tried meditation two solid times i
mean
solid attempts and it just doesn't
follow up holder
those are a couple of things that are
hard for me too have you tried them both
i oh yeah
yeah i have a journal and i don't i mean
like i was like oh every day i'll write
three things that i'm grateful for
it's classified i do like once or twice
and i'm like okay
like yes i don't know and then i can
tell you that journaling feels kind of
good when
i feel like i need to get something out
yeah or think things
through in a more thorough way than just
in my mind yeah i don't mind that but i
don't want to be
it's not a regiment it's just when i
feel it's nice
it's nice that the books the book is
actually a calendar as well as the
journal built
in so it's really easy it's right there
i'm using it virtually every day
um and then meditation i mean as far and
wide and deep as i
am into spirituality and all that whole
world and yoga
i just can't get myself to meditate me
too
this is the thing and it's like but
again i think like my whole thing having
done
what i've done for the last 10 years is
like there is no magic one-size-fits-all
solution
we each have to figure it out for
ourselves and there are tools that are
great for some people
and that just don't resonate with other
people and instead of being like what's
wrong with me
there's something wrong with me or like
i need to keep trying it's just like
yeah i gave it two good solid tries i'm
moving on
there's other things that i wanted like
opportunity costs like there's other
stuff to try
i find moving meditations to be more my
thing like going for a walk
i love going for a walk yeah so like i
was listening to one of your shows the
other day while i was out for a walk and
i would but that's
really meditation right because like
it's a different i was learning does
that help but
no but i don't think it's not i mean
another problem with meditation is like
now it's become so broad that people are
saying that just about anything is
meditation where i'm like
it's one thing to be a buddhist monk
who's sitting in silence and
like in focus for six hours that is not
the same thing as somebody sitting on
the subway with their eyes shut for two
minutes
i mean it just isn't the same thing i'm
not saying it's not valuable i'm just
saying okay it's starting to
like if i wander through the park just
with my mind flowing
i don't consider that meditation but i
find i find that very refreshing i agree
like a formal meditation what you're
referring to
i mean for me that would be like a
pillow just sit up sit down on the
ground and cross my legs
in the right spot okay thinking about my
breathing yep
i forget about that maybe even some
breath work and
that would be like proper meditation to
me um
but but i did i was told by a buddhist
monk that
my racing was probably my moving
meditation
now see i would think that's flow but i
wouldn't think that's meditation
it's very present and i think it's maybe
that's where the
maybe that's where his analysis of it
came in was that there's not a thought
about the future or the past right it's
far more present so
there's a flowing dance going on that is
it's very very present which i think is
very is
the point of meditation to some degree
now am i getting downloads from
guides and spirit and universe or source
or god or whatever you want to call
it yeah no right but am i
re-centering grounding and am i maybe a
just
like working on my brain to i would say
that that's analogous to like a surgeon
doing surgery
is the surgeon doing surgery meditating
like i think they're doing something
highly focused like this is what mihaiy
chick sent me how he says this flow it's
like
you're not having thoughts that are
you're not consciously yourself
you're you're kind of it's so focused
you're at the edge of your
expertise time kind of stops
everything is you know it's it's an it's
an extremely intense and sort of
impersonal thing and it's deeply
satisfying later
it's not even like you're enjoying it or
not enjoying it at the moment because
you just aren't in a place where you
even are experiencing emotion you know
i don't think that's meditation but then
probably there's somebody who's saying
it is meditation because everybody has
they're different
they have their different definitions
yeah yeah what uh what did you what did
you hang on to the longest like what was
the one thing
oh it was a happiness project that you
knew thanks
stuck hundreds hundreds of things we
only did 12.
oh but within each 12 there were several
and then more lists within the 12. well
there were there were the 12
themes and then each one had resolutions
had like three to five resolutions
and then i wrote happier at home which
was like another happiness project but
focused on home
wow and then was better than before i
was studying habits so like i do all
these stuff a habit that i used to have
that i dropped but i just read this
fascinating book called balance
by mccready so now i used to do the
thing where i would try to balance
on one foot when i was going up in the
elevator and on the other foot when i
was coming down
and now i'm going to start doing that i
kind of got out of that habit i'm still
doing it except for
for balance literally for balance just
balance on one foot and if you can do it
shut your eyes that makes it a lot
harder can you do it anytime anywhere
does it happen yeah you can
you can but i just for me that's because
you ride the elevator because i read the
elevator all the time but no you could
you could do it while you're waiting for
an elevator if you worked in an office
or you could do like or if you walk
on streets that have long like you're
brushing your teeth while you're
brushing your teeth and that'd be good
i've heard a lot of people doing while
they brushed their teeth actually
and that kind of like warning and the
right one at night yeah
i always have to do them both kind of at
the same time because i feel sort of
imbalanced if one because you feel
you feel it yeah you feel the muscle the
activation that it takes to
to offset it well that creates i mean
that's i mean it's totally off topic but
that totally
leads to injuries with people like
they'll have like a knee that hurts and
then they'll start hobbling
yes the hips get off oh yeah there's
always like this uh
yes and it's going all around across the
body yes yes yeah
interesting yeah well so i just i know i
just was learning all about the
vestibular
you know um sense and it's very
important have you ever thought about
doing
um like a second phase of happiness
project
well i did happier at home and that was
kind of the second phase
was it another year it was it was from
september to
mid to may which is the school year
which i feel like is the other year and
it started in september because
september sort of the other january
i think a lot of people get that feeling
of sort of a fresh start in september
it's like
after labor day you kind of come back
and you're like okay i'm back
um so i did that and um
but this i think my my next project is
going to be all about the body and
trying to find
happiness and kind of reach the
the mind through the body talk to me no
are you
in my zone yeah i would love to see yeah
i would love to hear any of your
thoughts i'm just in the exploratory
phase which is why i was reading a book
about balance because i'm like
what about vestibular you know like
proprioception but really i'm going to
focus on the big senses
the senses we think of i interviewed
joe dispenza i don't know if you've
heard of him but he talks a lot about
the mind
and reprogram reprogramming the mind
there's another guy bruce lipton who
talks a lot about reprogramming the
subconscious and
um whether it's through there's a few
modalities but
repetitions one yes hypnotherapy and
sort of uh retraining in the brain wave
states of
like we're in alpha oh right yeah beta
is a little slow
like uh theta and then delta biofeedback
type stuff
so that theta state is the is the one
where
we can sort of get downloaded programs
like it was interesting i was
talking to michael strahan for a show
and
he was saying that he had a problem with
finishing visually a tackle on someone
and because he played football
and so he went to a psychologist and the
psychologist gave him a tape what does
that mean
finish a tackle he was a defensive
lineman he played defense so he had to
tackle
[ __ ] but why he's
from what i've learned too that um from
from joe
dispenza that you know and i mean other
people i'm sure have
collected this information too but that
the the sub can
that the brain can't tell the difference
between an action that you think of that
hasn't happened
or has happened right or that other
people are doing too
right so if you imagine that you've done
something right you haven't done it
the activity still registers
in the body as if you have right it's so
so mind-blowing see now that's the kind
of thing that for this book i would be
like okay
can i try that like i would need to
think of something
in my own life and see if i could do it
like completing a tackle like i don't
have something like that like that's a
very great example so to finish that
story he
went to a psychologist and he gave him a
tape and he told him to play it
when he went to bed and he's like what
if i fall asleep he's like it doesn't
matter your brain your subconscious
never sleeps
so he had his best year and he was able
to visually finish tackles
so reprogramming the brain is this kind
of what you're talking about as far as
i'm taking and even well i'm very
interested in that um
i think i'm gonna do it even more like
sight smell
i'm like obsessed with the sense of
smell like those five
and then maybe pull out from there a
little bit but all these other things
i'm really interested in exploring and
trying to figure out kind of how to
my whole my whole thing is like to take
a gigantic subject and try to distill it
down into something that's like
all the interesting parts kind of
crystallized and made very accessible
so i have to cast a wide net so this is
great stuff
one of my favorite i wrote down my top
five favorite secrets of adulthood
oh yeah my top five favorite but the one
that um is so true is um
is is basically about what you do every
day matters more than what you do
sometimes
and that that would be like that would
contribute to
the the repetition yes to
create habits that make you happier
right yeah is that
i mean yeah the habits are important
habits are the invisible architecture of
everyday do you feel like that's part of
um your magic about the lists and
and addressing something so
repetitiously for an entire month or for
a quarter
i think so maybe yeah and i think that's
why i was led from the happiness project
into the study of habits because better
than before is all about like what are
the strategies people can use to make or
break habits because there's there's 21
different strategies that people use
effectively
um and i think it was because i was i
was seeing exactly that a lot of times
what you need to get the happiness
benefit from a behavior
it's not to do it one time anybody can
do it once it's how do you do it for the
next hundred years
you know consistently and that's when
you get into the problem of habits and
that's what got me interested in the
question of like
i can do this pretty easily like i quit
sugar overnight like
how did i do that other people can't do
that why could i do it what was
different about me what's different
about them
if they want to quit sugar in their own
way what would they do what what are the
other things do they even want to some
people don't want to
how do they see it differently from the
way i see it so that did lead me right
into
right straight into habits because so
often the things that we know would make
us happier
we want to make into habits things like
exercise or sleeping more meditating or
not
in our case or whatever do the habits
play into the tendencies do they go hand
in hand with
instructions in the book they do because
upholders
really tend to love habits and embrace
them
and have a lot of them questioners will
do things if they think they make sense
they won't do something so if
i say if i'm your doctor and i say you
need to take this medication
and you're like you know i really don't
think i need i don't think i have a
problem with blood pressure
i just won't take it it doesn't matter
that my doctor's telling me to
because i haven't convinced you why once
you're convinced why you'll take it fine
you're not going to take it until then
obliger it's like are you checking on me
if i say like i'm your doctor and you
know what
i get i get a call from your pharmacist
every time you
you get that prescription refilled so if
i see that you have not
need to refill your prescription i'm
asking myself how come she hasn't been
taking her medicine she should be out by
now
i'm watching you or i'm going to have my
nurse practitioner call you and be like
hey how's it going are you doing your
physical therapy
because if i feel like you're you're
holding me accountable i'll do it and
the rebel has to do it for their own
reasons they have to do it because they
want to
because it's their choice they're not
doing it because somebody tells them to
so a lot of times with habits they won't
even
like a rebel won't sign up for a 10 a.m
spin class
but a rebel might join a huge gym that
has
dozens of classes going at all different
times and they just show up and they're
like
i feel i'm feeling stiff i think i'll do
yoga today i'm feeling full of energy i
think i'll do cardio
i heard that zumba's fun and i've never
actually done it i think i'll take a
class like
they just do what they feel like that
works great for them
i would hate that i don't like
spontaneity
but that's what a rebel so for rubble
it's like people will try to get you to
sign up for the class
it's not going to work for a rebel
because they'll resist the class
but they can still exercise in their own
way so
of course the happiness project the next
the the question that you
you'd want answered is like what makes
you happy yes
is that a question possible to even
answer it is okay it's an interesting
question you can answer in two different
ways
if you had to say what is the secret to
happiness ancient philosophers and
contemporary scientists would agree
that the secret to happiness is
relationships that to be happy
people have to have strong intimate
bonds they we have to feel like we
belong
we have to feel like we can confide we
have to get support and give
support we have to feel connected to
other people and when you look at the
people that are happiest
it's the people that have the most
relationships if you look and see who's
happy at work it's the person who has a
friend at work
that's that's the most fundamental or
you could you could approach the
question in a different way and you sort
of alluded to this earlier
is you would say self-knowledge that we
could we can only build a happy life on
the foundation of our own nature our own
interests our own values our own
temperament
and i can't hand you a template you
can't do what your parents expect you
can't do what your friends are doing and
think it's going to make you happier
we each have to figure it out for
ourselves and so
that's also the secret to happiness
which is self-knowledge which is
sometimes painful to
confront sometimes we don't like what we
see
how do you write a book on that on
wishing you were different on the
self-knowledge like how do you write the
book on the
on the on the fact that there can't be a
book to just say this is right now
i know because people want like the one
page we want the pill right right
we just that's like was better than
before that's one of the things that's
like
there's 21 strategies in it and people
are like 21 is too many give me three
i'm like i can't give you three because
accountability works really well for
obligers but it doesn't work for rebels
or like um the strategy convenience
works for just about everybody because
if it's more convenient you're more
likely to do it
that works for just about everybody but
the strategy of scheduling works great
for upholders
it doesn't work for rebels the strategy
of clarity is the most important
strategy for questioners
for for other people it doesn't matter
and then there's ones that aren't even
like
tied to the tendencies like um the
strategy of the lightning bolt is a
weird i don't know if you've ever
experienced
this it's when you just get a new idea
or s or something happens oh and all of
a sudden
you're like i'm like like an epiphany
yeah it's like i'm pregnant i'm gonna
quit smoking and it's like
overnight it's effortless or like my i
was diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
everything in my life is going to change
yeah you know and it's overnight
yeah you just it is it's an epiphany
it's the easiest way to change habits
often it just happens suddenly
but sometimes people don't even they
don't even really understand what's
happening
because they're like this isn't how you
can't plan for that though you can't and
that's what's
that's what's frustrating about it
people are like this i want this how do
i make myself have a lightning bolt i'm
like
the other ones are within your control
lightning bolt is not within your
control
and then and also um first steps
um or clean slate that's when um
when if you have a new job a new
relationship you move moving is a great
time to change
change habits all old habits are wiped
away and then it's an easy time
much easier time for new habits to form
so we don't always have a clean slate
but you want to take advantage of it
when you have it because
like one when they look at people who
like quit smoking
huge percentage of people who
successfully quit smoking it's because
it's tied to
a move of home okay because all your old
associations are gone
sure so it's like are you moving are you
starting a new job or like
you know do you have a new puppy like
this is the time take advantage of it
again it's a strategy that isn't
available to everybody at all times
but if you know about it you can exploit
it when you can
how have you what things have happened
in your life that have
allowed you to um have epiphanies or
get happier or you know those moments
well i read a book called why we get fat
by gary tobbs and that's what totally i
gave
in like 2012 and i just gave up carbs it
was just like overnight i'm like okay
i've been out of carbs since 2012.
yeah basically i mean i don't i eat a
very low carb diet i mean i do eat nuts
i do eat leafy green vegetables
um you know phenomenal abdominal yeah
uh so and that happened just like
effortlessly i didn't do substitutions i
didn't do gradual change it was just
like overnight
um that's the most dramatic one where
i've had a change like that where just
overnight had changed
do you think you have to have a certain
mindset first to be open to anything
changing
is that kind of maybe even part of the
the book that you want to write
like you kind of you got to be open
right
you can't be in a state of i'm not
eating that
where's my meat and potatoes yeah well
you know it's that old joke about um
how many therapists does it take to
change a light bulb
only one but the light bulb has to want
to change
so you're right sometimes what you
there's something i call red herring
habits and a red herring habit is when
people say they want to change
but they don't like i remember talking
to this guy and he's like oh yeah i'm
going to start exercising
and just the way he said it in this flat
way and like with nothing
like just floating he's like i'm totally
going to start exercising my doctor says
i really need addiction my wife is
really on me and my kids are really on
me i'm going to
start exercising i'm like don't kid
yourself man just say i'm
like it's better to be honest with
yourself and be like you know right now
i'm just not in a place where i'm gonna
exercise
be honest self-knowledge and say this is
just not what
but to you're just like gonna frustrate
yourself and other people and you're
going to end up feeling like a failure
you haven't failed you haven't even
tried yeah admit that you're not even
trying
yeah but it's like nothing that anybody
said to this guy was going to make him
because
in his mind i could just feel it in the
way he was talking about it he wasn't
even yearning for
it it was just i'm gonna say the words
to get everybody off my back
so is it possible to crack someone right
to crack the crack someone that's
stubborn
or someone that maybe someone's
listening that's in a relationship
and you know they want to be happier and
they want to create some new patterns
and maybe they're in a partnership where
or in a marriage where you know one is
really stubborn and it makes it hard to
make those
to make those changes is it is it
possible to
implement any kind of strategies to
soften that person
or is it or is it not well i think the
sad truth about happiness
is that the only person that we can
change is ourselves
and so you can't change someone else
yeah but it is true that if i
change a relationship changes if i
change the relation
the atmosphere of my household changes
and so i think sometimes you can bring
about a larger change
by making change yourself but i think
sometimes people like with a happiness
project people are like i really want to
do this but my partner isn't excited i'm
like my partner's never been excited my
husband has never done one thing
he's not interested at all that's not
the guy i married i don't have to wait
for him to get on board
why would i frustrate myself in him it's
not his thing
um fine so i just do what but
does he benefit from it 100 would he
tell you that absolutely
and so i think sometimes it's almost a
procrastination technique
or sometimes it's a blighter's feeling
like well i know i'm not going to be
able to do it unless somebody else does
it with me
so i know i would exercise if we would
exercise together i know i could
exercise
false but you don't exercise so i can't
i'm like okay we'll find somebody else
get a dog who needs to go for a walk
every day or like take your neighbor's
dog or you know there's a million ways
to get
so i think it's a mistake to think that
um
that you need other people to come on
board now sometimes out of deep love
we wish people would change because
they're doing something that we think is
not
good for them right and that is very
hard
um but um
you know andy warhol who i think is like
a brilliant writer i don't even like his
art he's a brilliant
brilliant oh thinker yeah i don't i only
know
him for art i know oh my gosh he's this
incredible i've read everything he ever
said or wrote
he's incredible but he has this thing
and he says it in this warhol way but he
basically says
you know you can't make people change
they only change when they want to
change and sometimes they die before
they change
and it's like you know at a certain
point it's like
i can't i can't i can't keep you like
right now i can support you by like if
you say things like
i don't want to this is where it gets
tricky
i say to you i think you should eat more
healthfully
and you say okay please don't buy ice
cream i don't like to have it in the
house i can't resist it and i'm like
you should learn to manage yourself
better just have a half a dish of ice
cream
or i don't understand why i should have
to give up ice cream if you can't manage
yourself it's like
do you want to be helpful right because
if a person is saying to you i can't
control myself there's ice cream in the
refrigerator maybe you just need to say
like okay i'll have ice cream
right during the day or whatever i mean
sometimes i think people
have unrealistic or they're like you
should be able to do it the way i do it
i only have a little bit you should be
like me
why like and that's the that's i call
that the abstainer moderator
abstainers are people who can are like
all or nothing they can have none or
they can have a ton but they can't have
a little bit and the moderators
they can have one square of fine
chocolate or half a dish of ice cream or
two
thin mint cookies i can't do that and
moderators are always telling me there's
something wrong with me
you know and it's like it's not that one
of us is writing one of us is wrong it's
just like i can
i can have no sugar very easily or i can
have a lot of sugar
i can't have a little sugar it's too
hard for me well making those rules
whatever it helps to implement whether
it's someone to call you at three to go
to the movies or
whether it's not having the ice cream in
the house whatever it may be
um you know that you have to implement
whatever it takes but i think that maybe
when it comes to being happy and in your
scenario sometimes there needs to be an
acknowledgement for
your own happiness someone else's
happiness is not worth sacrificing your
own and
i think there's like a lack of bravery
perhaps at times when people don't feel
like they
um want to make too big of changes
because not sure what's going to happen
right what if things fall away because i
i do feel like as i've evolved and
changed and
found ways to be happier and be more
myself
well now all of a sudden my energy my my
habits my frequency is at this in this
new space now where guess what we're not
resonating anymore yes
and things fall away yes jobs fall away
people fall
friend relationships friendships um
these things fall away and change is
really scary
so i think maybe there's that attachment
to the familiarity
yes of things but i think sometimes too
the worst
but sometimes when people make positive
change it also makes others feel
guilty or judged right um or maybe like
they lost their partner in crime right
like i want you to drink because we have
so much fun when we go out drinking and
if you're only having one glass of wine
like
i've lost my drinking buddy and it's
like right
well maybe that's just not maybe i just
can't play that role for you anymore
maybe we need to go out for brunch or
maybe we need to go for a hike
or maybe we're just not going to be as
good of friends anymore because we've
sort of come to the concept of evolving
what is it as you say it can be very
painful what are your thoughts about
evolving
as a person oh i mean i think it's great
i think everyone i think
you know a key aspect of happiness is an
atmosphere of growth we're all happier
when we feel like we're growing
when we're learning or teaching when
we're somehow making things better
making ourselves better
but sometimes the atmosphere of growth
it's like it can be frustrating you can
feel insecure
you can feel stupid you don't know what
you're doing it can be scary
but it's really important i think to
have that sense of energy and vitality
because if you're not changing if you're
not growing you can start feeling
stagnant even if things are pretty good
and you're pretty happy
yeah you start to feel kind of like
stagnant
yeah well you know then there's this
whole theory too where i feel like
you know somebody says you've changed
it's supposed to be a negative
if somebody tells me you've changed i'm
like well i hope so i've been working on
it that's interesting
i feel like i'm more myself than ever
and kind of like an almost
so much but it might might be a change
uh-huh
maybe my mannerisms change maybe my
maybe the way i
maybe my lightness changes maybe my
hobbies even change yes
but maybe it's not because i'm becoming
less of myself but i'm becoming more
and in this day and age it's just so
hard to know who you are yeah
do you think larry o'connor is this
beautiful thing where she says
accepting oneself does not preclude the
attempt to become better
well say that again accepting oneself
does not preclude
the attempt to become better and i think
that's right it's like you want to
accept yourself but you want to
expect more from yourself and sometimes
that means that
you that that things are different um i
remember when i
because i'm kind of like like a you know
tightly wound kind of like you know
uh like racing dog kind of personality i
would i
that's my perception of myself remember
after i had my first daughter
and i was just like i was just
overwhelmed and like
just kicking back and my mother was
staying with us
and she's like i have never seen you
relax like this
right because i was like i'm in a
totally different state
yeah and that last change six weeks but
yeah but it was like usually if somebody
says you've changed they're saying it
because you've
you're however you are now makes me
uncomfortable yes
right so you think there's sort of a
hidden accusation of course that's more
their feeling about you as a reflection
of themselves not of you
so much like even though you've kind of
evolved
it's not it's not like okay look you've
changed it's like
now you're a drug addict problem right
that's that's a bad
change or it's like now you have a fancy
job
right right now you don't live in our
hometown anymore
like you've got your big city ways
whatever right
yeah right i think that while the
evolution of us
as a person there can be change in it
the accusation of changing
comes from someone's discomfort so maybe
the thing is does story say like
thank you thank you very much thank you
that's really lovely
yeah that is a new that's right that's
fantastic
you've changed thank you thank you
reframed the yeah yeah yeah yeah
the the accusation or the uh
yeah the challenge i guess yeah yeah
yeah because right you're supposed to be
like i haven't changed but as
you say we want to change yeah yeah
trying to get better every day yes
writing in my journal when i can
yeah you know i'm trying to be
spiritually more
um educated and learn myself but i think
one of the biggest things that's helped
me become happier
is figuring out who i am but that isn't
easy
so whatever do you agree with do you
agree with this i think it's the great
challenge of our lives
do you feel like you know who you are no
i think about it all the time
i know i have 12 personal commandments
the first one is to be gretchen and i'm
always like what does that even mean i
don't know
so what have you done like do you have
exercises or practices or like
insights that have come to you about
yeah i would say that the
the the the one thing that's been the
most helpful
for me to know who i am and i got some
insight into this
a few years ago um because i was just i
had a lot of time
that it's basically time alone i was
sort of i was in a relationship but i
was alone a lot
and i was in the middle of nowhere in
north carolina
with really nothing to do and on a big
giant piece of property
and was like what do i do and i had to
like when you're by yourself you're not
going to do anything you totally don't
want to do
unless it's maybe something like clean
or picking right
you know something that just kind of
needs to be done around the house then
with the rest of your time
right what do you do right and you don't
do anything that you don't want to do at
all right so you do stuff that you're
kind of interested in
yeah and that you kind of want to do
yeah and then you're like oh that was
kind of nice and then you kind of you
know
find a way to maybe build it up a little
bit more so for me it was uh
yoga and then i you know got a room for
it and then i
was kind of off to the side and then i
cleared everything out and made it my
own room and i called it my woman cave
and then i was like
you know i i remember i kind of like
being creative i'm gonna go get some
arts and crafts and then you know
because i had the idea
well i kind of like maybe build
something or like draw a little bit but
i didn't have anything
so i was like well go get a bunch of
supplies so that when it strikes me
right it's here and i can just do it so
then i had a whole bunch of arts and
crafts and i got a sewing machine
and all these little things started to
fill in and i realized i like doing all
these things right
but i didn't know that right you didn't
really know
right that this was part of who i was i
didn't really know i was that spiritual
i didn't really know that um i liked to
you know take long walks at the dogs and
really get with my thoughts and be in
nature i didn't realize that was an
important thing to me
um so recently i took a trip by myself
for five days and i've always wanted to
take a solo trip
and one of the really great revelations
on that trip was i would be like i'm
like you
i feel like a race dog i feel like yeah
i'm obviously a race but
i feel like a good girl go like i'm yeah
i'm the fastest walker i'm in front of
everybody
go go go what's next let's let's let's
work hard when we're working
yeah and when i was there when i was by
myself
i was the one thing that was super odd
to me
was i walked really slow
interesting and i was like why
do i walk so fast all the time
so i've been to the same place with my
friends before
so i'm not even like taking the city
into right right where i'm at right i've
been at the same place
with friends with nothing to do
essentially right
and i'm walking fast leading the way
where are we going i'm by myself and i'm
like whatever
i don't know what i'll do today and i'm
going to go here and
interesting i'm just walking much slower
and
oh well and stop and you know take in
the sight
like i'm just slowed way down and i
realized that
somehow when i'm with people it makes me
feel like i need to prove something oh
so sort of like this comp almost like a
competitive spirit yeah
needing to be the leader so out of the
front yeah that's but that's a little
controversial story to say that
being alone i find that to be the most
beneficial way to know who i am
related to that that's so interesting i
want to think about that more but
one of the things advice i give to
people who don't know what they want to
do with their career
is i'm like well do what you do and i'm
like what do you do meaning what do you
do
when you when you can choose what you do
so like a friend of mine um she was part
of this big management
program and she was offered this
position where she this
like it could have had this great media
job where she would be all like
moving between and this was when
magazines were still big and she would
go
and be highly trained and and she's like
yeah i think i want to be like
editor-in-chief of a women's magazine
and i was like
it's funny i never see read women's
magazines and she's like well i never
read them and i'm like
i don't think that you'd be good at
creating them you know what i mean or
like a friend of mine my sister who is a
tv writer she said to me
i just wish i'd watched more tv as a
child because that's what she does now
and so i think part of it is like
what do you do in your free time are you
making things out of arts and crafts are
you
you know um somebody said that when uh
somebody i know who's like a tv and a tv
news anchor said that
she her when she was little she would
pretend to have a microphone and she
would sit
and narrate stories looking at herself
in the mirror for hours
that's probably her thing then right
it's like what do you do and so i think
that your thing like
go by yourself and just observe what
happens
when you're free of the to-do list
and what to do list some people would be
like of course
like a friend of mine said oh i had to
get a summer job so of course i went to
work at a florist i'm like why would you
why do you say of course she goes well
everybody wants to work at a florist i'm
like
it's literally never crossed my mind i
mean right but do you
think you think you think other people
would automatically make the choices you
would
i assure you 95 of people would now be
like why don't i do some yoga some
people would
but most people that wouldn't be on the
top five of their list or maybe they'd
be like i should do yoga i'm all this
time i should do yoga they'll do it one
time and then not do it again
you know so you're right that's how you
figure it out
what do you do what have what has led
you to any any conclusions about
yourself
like who is gretchen that you know so
far well one of the things that i think
is harder for me is to let go of all the
things i wish i were
that's what i would call the fantasy
self so like in my mind like
everybody loves music i'm not that into
music
everybody loves food i'm just i'm not
dying to food like i don't really care i
like diner food
the best fun so you know
i'm not that into food like if i were on
a trip by myself i probably wouldn't go
to restaurants
oh wow i like was a little different
i would just like eat from a whole food
like i just i'm not that into food
and yet i see that it's so it's like
this rich vibrant part of culture and
people love it and it brings people
together and it's fun
and it's exciting and it's interesting
and it and not that into food
um you know i don't like games
i mean i don't even like a game like
scrabble
i just don't like games um and i i just
sound like such a killjoy
but that i have a pretty killjoy
personality well it's okay to know what
you don't want
i mean it's like in racing we would when
we'd go when we'd test different setups
and
things like that you'd it was beneficial
to know what you don't like to do
aka what what changes didn't work yeah
and you don't do them again
right like if you're you're probably not
going to enjoy
a trip to um uh
you know napa valley to go like 100
tasting wine and
eating food because you're like i just
don't really care
i know i know right so you at least you
know
but it is important to know what you do
like oh well so here's a good example
this is part of something i did for the
happiness project is i realized that
this was a long time ago and at this
time
nobody really talked about children's
literature since then there's been
twilight harry potter hunger games so
now a lot of people give a lot of credit
to children's literature but at that
time
no adults really talked about reading it
but i love children's literature i've
read it my whole life
children's literature and young adult
literature and i realized i always
thought it sort of didn't fit with the
personality i wanted to present to the
world which was very sophisticated
i loved i read a ton i think of myself
as a very sophisticated reader
you are a big reader yeah i'm a big
reader and when i saw you what you read
three books in like a day or a week or
something yeah
yes but yeah but but i
i but i never talked about my love of
children's literature young adult
literature because i felt like it didn't
fit
like i'm like i don't have so many
things that i love
that i can toss one away
and so i started thinking about well
could i have i'm in a book group or
regular book group i'm like well could i
have a children's literature reading
group could i find
other adults you should write children's
literature well see it's very different
i'm not a novelist i like to read it
but i'm just like i like to read novels
but i don't want to write them
and people are like do you read it with
your children i'm like not really it's
part of your joy it's not something that
just brings you happiness yes and so but
the funny thing is is once
i sort of proclaimed it then i found all
these people in the world
who also love it and they are all like
super bookish writerly people
and it ended up being the most networky
thing i could possibly have done
yeah with a bunch of people who
we got together because we love children
like these are the people who want to
talk about harry at the spy
for like two hours and um it's not for
everyone but
it's brought me so much joy and all the
people in the group say it's one of the
things that makes them happiest because
it's like
it's something that not everybody shares
what a great story though to
say something that was uncomfortable or
you thought people would judge or would
take away from you in some way
in your education and and and and all of
a sudden it brought
you that truth there's so much power and
truth there's so much power and there's
so much authenticity
in truth and it's the whole your vibe
will attract your tribe thing
you know oh i've never heard that phrase
really oh that's so great i'm collecting
proverbs like this
your vibe will attract your tribe
attracts your tribe that's
so true you did that but not that is
very true
it's exactly what happened of being
brave enough to just be who you are
and be honest no matter what you're you
know i used to say to myself
in past relationship but you know like i
used to say being
very spiritual and hippie was just weird
and my friend kept telling me she's like
it's not weird she's like you think
you're on an island but you're not
you're gonna realize that there's
a whole lot of people think just like
you and sure enough
as soon as i was able to be more myself
in that way
they were everywhere i'm not interested
so
we're sometimes not comfortable with
these things
because they're ins they somehow feel
insecure about them yeah but our
but if it's our truth i feel like it's
always going to be
respected i think that's right i think
that's right and i think people do have
a lot more
either they're not interested because it
doesn't resonate with them or maybe
or you find that you have all these
secret um
you know compatriots sure you know yeah
you had no idea that you
had something in common with someone
well like it was so deep or somebody
that you didn't even think you liked
you're like oh man you gotta know that
right hello yeah well like i and i go
through sort of obsessions like i was
really interested in color
and all these people are like constantly
sending me something color i went
through this thing like i was obsessed
with the life of dolly parton i'm not
even that interested in her music it's
like andy warhol i don't care about his
heart
um but i was obsessed with sort of like
her
name her character and
because and now all these people are
constantly sending me stuff about dolly
park because they're like i know you're
really into dolly parton and i love
deliberating too and i'm like it's so
fun i have like
the world is my research assistant it's
like i don't miss a thing
in these like weird little things that i
track because you're also really instant
into winston churchill oh yeah i wrote a
biography winston churchill yeah
but i would just love to know a quick
like what is so fascinating about
winston churchill
think about that convince me sell me
winston churchill is the most
fascinating person who ever lived i mean
and i wrote my biography thinking
there's all these like nine volume
and it's like it's too much for the
average person i'm like my book is like
the one that's meant to be like the
gateway drug where you read this and
you're like okay now i'm ready for the
two volume now i'm ready for the nine
volume because he's just so fascinating
think about winston churchill he held
every position
he was involved in everything of
importance he knew everybody
he was part of everything he
is so he was part of everything that
happened during his lifetime in
just an unbelievable way from the time
he was very young
to the time he died he he's a brilliant
writer i mean just as i learned so much
from studying his writing let alone all
this statesmanship which is like okay
that's somebody's career
he's this magnificent writer like i
learned so much just about
um construction and like how to present
things
and also you know world war ii
is endlessly fascinating
the stakes were so high the numbers were
so huge
the situations were so immense
and churchill really grasped the
magnitude of it and the monumental
nature of the time and he really
embraced it in a way that's very
kind of hard to wrap your mind around he
really loved a war
in a way that is interesting to me he
was very sad
he said um like after after the war was
over he's
saying to one of his advisers he goes
well you know we can't have a war all
the time
you know because he loved kind of the
just the intensity of it and
the drama of it and the historic nature
of it so you know this very
sweeping imagination saying but it's not
sustainable we can't have a war all the
time
uh no yeah you can or that the fun will
be gone yeah no
well it's i mean you kind of have to see
it from his perspective i mean he really
it is interesting and the thing is it's
funny because my biography the way i
approached it was like it's called 40
ways to look at wednesday churchill so i
look at him in all different ways
and so like the first chapter is like a
short biography of churchill that's all
positive and then i go through and i
tell the very same story it's all
perfectly factual and it's like the very
negative it's like if you're really
gonna emphasize the dark side
the negative side the imperialism the
warmongering the impulsivity
like all these kinds of things it's all
there it's all true
and so the whole every chapter looks at
them from a different angle and so
sometimes people would email me and
they're like
you said all these great things about
winston churchill but what about this
what about this what about this i'm like
you're quoting from my book i wrote
about those negative things about
churchill i know them perfectly well i
put them in there
because what i wanted to capture was
that no one's all
he was not all hero he was also did a
lot of
you know um things that we would
criticize him for
um so we all have to kind of make up our
own mind about how do we
come out in the balance and so you know
in the end i say here's my churchill
um but i have fun like showing all the
different ones that you could
your passion for winston churchill has
me sold to just read that oh
it's short it's a super fun book and it
he is i'm not a big history about
like as in i'm not even that interested
in history
but sometimes there's some magic in
in just starting to understand the human
nature of someone well
he's such a gigantic figure yeah
yeah such a gigantic okay we'll have to
read it um
okay so i want to talk about my favorite
my top five secrets to adulthood okay
yes and i kind of want to hear what your
like what your favorite secrets to
adulthood were okay i love these
um it's okay to ask for help yes
why is that so hard why is that so so
hard
we're most helpful helpless when we real
when we think that there's no help
if you're not failing you're not trying
hard very true
right enjoy the fun of failure
well it means you probably set your
goals high enough yes you know
right yeah i always i say i always say
and say to myself and say to anyone else
when there's a contemplation of what to
do next or
basically a way to grow really and
that's that you don't grow from your
comfort zones
right yes and you're gonna fail if
you're not in your comfort zone probably
because you're not gonna know how to do
it
right exactly exactly exactly and you
see other people's successes and you
don't see their failures so you don't
realize how often other people are
failing
so true so true we see the highlight
reel yeah we do
and we see the things that are working
you know you don't see the things that
aren't working yeah there are a lot of
people that
um i interviewed john paul de jouria who
started paul mitchell and patron
and various other companies but in the
conversation so it sounds like he you
know yeah
like everything he does it turns out
yeah and he's like i've had tons of
failures
and you're like wow you know what it it
that's right
like you you just don't focus on those
things right but there's a great podcast
called without fail
and he interviews people who have had
spectacular failures
and it's it's really interesting uh
you also learn a lot about a person when
there's failure and yourself
you don't have to be good at everything
yes i try
that's very hard you try not anymore i'm
like i'm gonna let some things go
i think to do some things well you have
to do some things badly
i've i'm growing to enjoy um not
being good at a couple of something or
actually not not to enjoy it but to
acknowledge
what i'm not good at instead of trying
to cover it up or pretend like i'm good
yeah like for instance when it came to
doing this podcast
one of my ideas for something to do
after my career was i was like i love
cooking i have a cooking show
i did a couple cooking shows and you're
in a place with no windows
and it's all very programmed and
you know there's like the cooking is
actually a byproduct of like whatever
the concept of the show is and things
went by
and i was like i can't be the bubbly
person that's on tv
i'm like i'm serious and so i just
realized
let it go let it go danica you're not
that person
you're this person but guess what
they're not rather than you're trying to
change yourself and beat yourself
up yeah i realize i'm just not i'm not
happy-go-lucky enough to
i like that you see on tv serious yeah
because that is one of these words that
people are like
they don't use that to describe
themselves that much
that's interesting and then we covered
it what you do every day matters than
what you do once in a while
absolutely what do you do once in a what
do you do
every day now that you didn't do every
day that has made a big difference
i get up every day at six i really do
feel like that helps me sleep better
like fall asleep faster and like
um even like if i go to the west coast
if i'm only there for a couple days i'll
try to stay on east coast time
i mean eventually the sunlight will move
you forward but
um so i get i mean it's christmas day
it's sunday
it's a holiday like why do you feel like
that makes you well part of it is well i
think the regularity it helps me just
like
fall asleep i hate to like toss and turn
so i like i think it makes it easier for
me to fall asleep
but also like i love the early morning
and so i don't like giving it up
and i finally realized like i it's not
just that i
want it's like i really like that i
don't want to
i don't want to forego it it's like it's
more fun to get up and enjoy the morning
than it is to sleep light
i love the quiet right i like when
people aren't out there i know i love it
especially in new york like there's no
traffic and like when i walk my dog it's
very quiet and i just like being in the
quiet
so being in the city all week like the
the third floor room
it isn't quiet until six in the morning
like six to seven i'm like oh god what
am i supposed to get up i wanted to work
out well um but six to seven it seems
like it's quiet so
yeah um this one i love because
i've just been in situations where i'm
guilted or feel like i need to do a
better job in this area
but when i read this i was like yes yes
yes yes yes
because you're working off of your
intuition
your gut feeling and your belief that
something is going to work
and that's most decisions don't require
extensive research
yeah i loved that one well it's also
like sometimes people just
tie themselves up in knots and you're
like there's no wrong decision here or
you know i mean
yeah we just you can just move ahead and
you can just know what you know
just go with it because you can spin
your wheels and spend a lot of time on
things
i realize this um and maybe you've
experienced this too like
i'll work with people like i have to
redesign my website every couple of
years which is like one of the things
that i dislike doing the most it's very
hard
and i used to really get in the weeds
and like
you know tinker tank or tinker and then
finally i'm like
i have a delegate i have a great team
they know what they're doing
the changes i make are so minor they
really are insignificant i'm spending a
huge amount of time and energy on
something
it's not moving the needle at all it's
really just
distracting me from things that are much
more high value for me
these are decisions that don't like
they've already they know what they're
doing
they're trained i don't have to do
extensive research on to like should we
use
this size circle in the bullet or this
side circle in the bullet or i don't
like that shading it's like okay it's
fine like i call that diminishing
returns on my investment of time
exactly i can accomplish a lot more by
doing something else
than trying to comb through something
that's already been combed through right
well and it's like the sake of it
the um don't rearrange the deck chairs
on the titanic it's kind of like the
positive version of that it's like it's
our the plane is already going to take
off
yeah it doesn't matter if you change the
color of the bathroom
yeah like tile yeah do you have some
favorite secrets to adulthood
or maybe even some like new ones oh
we'll see okay so funny thing
is i now i'm doing this giant project
which is kind of a side project from my
main book that i'm writing but it's all
about aphorism so secrets of adulthood
i think it's aphorism so an aphorism is
like those are really
i would now call them aphorisms so an
aphorism is a truth
it's like a general truth that's sort of
um pithily
explained so what you do every day
matters more than what you do and so on
that's an aphorism
um so now i'm like trying to generate
these all the time i want to do a whole
collection
so i'm trying so i have like a million
let me think of my some of my favorites
one of mine
is red is the salt of color
what does that mean you have to think
like it's like it's like it's the
it's the thing that you add to like life
oh
yeah yeah yeah good yeah
yeah another one okay that took a lot of
thinking and i
um i'm kind of embarrassed but it's my
truth okay here's one that's not
very well said but i think it's very
true because i'm always categorizing
things like you're an abstainer or a
moderator or you're an upholder a
question of why you're rubbing people
are like
what about categories so categories lack
the precision of
continua but they're simpler to
understand and therefore more powerful
in the mind wow i feel like um
could you say that one more time
categories lack the precision of
continuum
but they are easier to remember and
therefore more powerful in the mind
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay like let
me think of some other things very
identifiable then yeah
um oh why put a
strong lock on a weak door
the most significant link in the chain
is the weakest
because it's the one that can break the
chain yeah that's great
that's a great one so um anyway so i'm
like trying to
and also i'm collecting what i would
call proverbs of the professions which
is like
you spot it you got it or like somebody
says somebody who is a cheese monger and
like a wine specialist said
things that grow together go together
yeah or like my father's
um said of a judge if he'll do it for
you he'll do it to you
so do you have any problems with the
professions for for
any like anything any proverbs that you
can think of
oh gosh now i'm like like your vibe
attracts your tribe that's a great point
um uh let's see i mean i would call like
for me i like
mantras yeah yeah yeah those things that
i really repeat to myself
um i mean i i like the young ones for me
were like
carpe diem which yeah what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger oh that's yeah
i mean those are pretty traditional yeah
um
i'll thank myself tomorrow yes that's a
good one
that's a very upholding one yeah right
i'm like if i don't eat that cake i'll
thank myself tomorrow and i always do
let's think i'm on the spot now i know
they're hard they're like
flash cards that it's hard to bring it
up it's more like they come up in
context so i'm trying to like
be listening to them i say try harder
all the time um
that's just words but uh try harder
um i can't think of any more off the top
of my head i feel i wish i had someone
but like the vibe in the treble like
that just came out so i'm like
i'm constantly listening for people to
um
like what was another one somebody just
told me the other day oh um
uh someone was saying uh
a teacher was saying that one thing they
say is children save the drama for the
mama
but i'm only saying the rhyming ones
because those are sort of easy to
remember but a lot of the proverbs
oppressions don't
like finance people say don't try to
catch a falling knife
um a rising tide rises raises lifts all
boats
i don't know if this one i'd say don't
don't confuse effort with accomplishment
ooh that's a good one uh permission
no patience not permission
what is i've heard ask forgiveness on
permission what's patience not
permission
well if someone is working on something
and then you give you have patience for
them but
there has to be at some point in time
where you identify
when you're just giving them permission
to act like they are
oh ooh interesting
there's a difference between it right
permission is allowing you to do
something but
i am allowing you to do something during
my patience
but if i don't see progress so there
could be another p in there it could be
like um
patience not permission during progress
or something
patience something like that but
patience patience not permission for
sure that's just
for people like christine yeah
all right well i came up with something
okay well then i'm thinking i have an
afrozone that's something like
inattention
fosters it's i said it better than this
i hope
it's something like inattention fosters
wrongdoing because i think sometimes
when people feel like they're getting
away with something
they'll do it more oh yeah and the more
they get away with it the worst they get
that's the permission and it's the
permission
and it's like i'm not giving you
permission and at some point
that hammer is going to come down but
the inattention has basically led them
into wrongdoing
but i hadn't thought about patience not
permission okay i want that's a good one
thanks yeah i appreciate you yeah yeah
yeah well yeah i would like to ask my
final question just ask
what your greatest life lesson has been
so far it's got to be that there's no
magic one-size-fits-all solution we all
have to figure it out for myself i need
to be gretchen
and everybody has to substitute their
own name because there isn't
there isn't a there's not like the seven
bullets that are going to do it for
everyone some people should
stay up late and some people should get
we get up early and you know i mean
some people start working early and
you know and then other people like to
work against a deadline
some people want more adventure in their
life some people want more routine
um some people love to travel some
people love to watch movies i mean it's
just
everybody's got to figure these things
out for themselves
you got to figure yourself out yes well
thank you for giving us so many books to
help do that
yeah we didn't talk about it really much
but the outer order intercom is your new
book which
you know i i i actually i was told
this i'm actually fairly organized but
it does feel
good it feels good there's some magic in
it
aaron and uh i think that that's a
wonderful recommendation for people to
um
something that's a tangible thing yes it
is like you said it's not something
general like
i wanna you can get it done in an
afternoon you can have
massive progress it's very exciting in
half an hour you can have massive
progress
that sounds like a magic pill to me it
is
it is oh thank you so much thank you
it's so fun to talk to you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button